can you guys see him through recovery
yeah I'll take it no I can do it it's
common practice for doctors to scrub up
before performing surgery or delivering
babies but this was not always the case
in the mid 19th century Dr Ignat
semelweis was the first to figure out
how to prevent doctors from spreading a
deadly infection to pregnant women in
1846 he was appointed as an assistant in
the maternity ward of the renowned
Vienna General Hospital while there he
noticed something peculiar the maternal
mortality rate in the ward run by
doctors and medical students was
significantly higher than an award run
by midwives between 1841 to 1846 four
women out of 100 died in the clinic run
by midwives whereas the one handled by
doctors and medical students had a
striking 10 women out of 100 lose their
lives why would mortality rates be so
different between the two Wards
simulvise was baffled and wrote
everything was in question everything
seemed applicable everything was
doubtful only the large number of deaths
was an unquestionable reality pregnant
women assigned to the ward with the
doctors begged to be transferred to the
other Ward they were so afraid they
prefer to give birth on the streets
where they had a lower chance of dying
from the mysterious disease simulvise
vowed to get to the bottom of what was
going on then in March 1847 came a
breakthrough his colleague Jacob
kolechka had performed an autopsy and a
student accidentally pricked his finger
with the scalpel he died from an
infection similar to the one that
Afflicted the women
simulvise realized doctors started each
day performing autopsies on the women
who had died shortly after giving birth
and then examine pregnant women without
washing their hands whereas The Midwives
had never handled dead bodies he
hypothesized that the doctors were
transferring some kind of cadaverous
particles from the dead bodies to the
pregnant women doctors at the time
didn't know that bacteria caused
infections they believed diseases were
caused by bad odors humidity the stress
of giving birth or some kind of
imbalance in the body bacterial
infections entering the reproductive
tract can cause severe complications
during or after birth an infection known
as pure parole fever or child bed fever
can lead to intense fevers bowel
smelling discharge and excruciating pain
death often occurred within days of
giving birth newborns could also
contract the infection and die
so semelvice ordered his medical staff
to wash their hands with a disinfectant
chemically related to chlorine to remove
the smell of decaying corpses before
attending to the pregnant women the
mortality rate dropped immediately in
1848 the clinic run by doctors and
medical students fell to one death per
100 births which was slightly below the
rate of the clinic run by midwives when
semovies wrote to the heads of several
maternity clinics about his Discovery
you'd think they'd be eager to embrace
hand washing but they refused the
prominent American obstetrician Charles
Meigs famously said doctors are
gentlemen and gentlemen's hands are
clean many doctors pushed back against
the suggestion that they were to blame
for their patients deaths it didn't help
that semovies waited 13 years before
officially publishing his findings in
which he lamented my teachings are
either ignored or attacked he continued
to urge the medical community to listen
to him writing this truth must be made
known to everyone concerned his book was
long and included heavily convoluted
passages that didn't help his case
simulvise was also difficult to deal
with he's been described as having a
temper like a rattlesnake and was
outrageously rude to anyone who
questioned his ideas said Dr Irvin
Louden who was a medical historian and
author of The Tragedy of child bed fever
not long after semovies made his
Discovery the head of the obstetrics
department at Vienna General Hospital
refused to renew his contract another
example of the resistance to his ideas
he abruptly left Vienna to return home
to Budapest where he worked at a
hospital and continued to advocate for
hand washing despite virtually
eliminating maternal mortality at the
hospital in Budapest his ideas were
still rejected the professor of
obstetrics at the University of pest
head of Florian Burley maintained his
belief that childbed fever was caused by
uncleanliness of the bowel when Burley
passed simulvise took over his position
at the University and grew increasingly
erratic he wrote angry letters to his
critics calling them irresponsible
murderers he became severely depressed
and began drinking heavily and spending
more time away from his wife and five
children and in the company of
prostitutes the university fired him for
his inappropriate behavior
it's believed he may have developed
early onset dementia or perhaps the
criticism of his life's work caused him
to suffer a mental breakdown
in 1865 Austrian physician Ferdinand
Ritter von Habra lured him to a mental
asylum in Vienna under the premise of
showing semovies the facilities
when symbolize realized he was actually
being admitted as a patient he tried to
leave that's when several guards beat
him up put him in a straight jacket and
threw him into a cell he died two weeks
later at the age of 47. very few people
attended his funeral
his autopsy revealed he died from blood
poisoning from a wound on his hand that
he could have sustained from the beating
ironically the man who spent his life
fighting against the spread of
infections died from an infection
two years after his death French
microbiologist Louis Pasteur made a
Monumental Discovery pastel realized
that bacteria were spoiling wine and
that these microorganisms were not only
responsible for spoiling food and drink
but also for spreading infectious
diseases
unlike paste semovies had not taken the
time to examine particles under a
microscope had he been a more diligent
scientist he would have seen that they
were teeming with bacteria which could
have made his case for hand washing more
convincing
pastel's work inspired Scottish surgeon
sir Joseph Lister to introduce the
concept of antiseptics the practice of
using chemical agents to prevent the
growth of bacteria on living tissue
Listerine is named after Dr Lister
by this point semovies was all but
forgotten Lister had never even heard of
him
hand washing and sterilizing medical
instruments finally started to become
standard practice in the 1860s 20 years
after semovies warned doctors about the
importance of hygiene how does
sanitation techniques been implemented
earlier there's no telling how many
lives he could have saved given that the
death rate for women who gave birth in
hospitals was as high as 20 percent in
some instances it could have been in the
hundreds of thousands or even more
it was only decades later that
symbolwise finally started to gain
recognition as the medical community
became more receptive of The Germ theory
of disease he's now widely known as the
savior of mothers
semelvice once said when I look back
upon the past I can only dispel the
sadness which falls upon me by gazing
into that happy future when the
infection will be banished
sadly he never lived to see the day
as we've seen with symbolwise's work the
power of scientific thinking can lead to
life-saving advancements if you'd like
to sharpen your science technology
engineering and math skills I recommend
brilliant.org a website and app where
you can learn through physical Insight
my viewers especially love their
scientific thinking course where you can
for example figure out how to make this
bridge as rigid as possible with as few
beams as possible there's everything
from computer science to foundational
and advanced math to data science
brilliant is great for both beginners
and those who want to improve on what
they already know which is crucial to
help you stay ahead in today's
competitive Marketplace as you progress
through their lessons you can dive
deeper into more advanced topics I
personally use brilliant to boost my
analytical thinking skills by going
through their logic puzzles brilliant
supports you every step of the way if
you're stuck you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong
you can try out brilliant for free for
30 days by heading to the custom link in
my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who sign up with my link will get
20 off their premium subscription which
gives you access to all the offerings
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm